に残っているのは心に
体に 心に対する執着を捨てるだけなんです
そこは四行目で三行目でチェットアナマーラッサパプッパカーニという心の執着も捨てなさいと言っているんです
このパプッパが花がついているという言葉が
言葉の本当の解説はないんです
これどうしよう あの花一ツなんですね
この矢に矢が だからお釈迦様はこの文学的な例えを使ってますから
あまりやたらには使わないんですよ
だから キューピッドの矢がこの花一ツでできているんだから
この一ツに何か意味があるはずなんです
で そこら辺まではブッダゴセ長老は考えてないんです
で お釈迦様は無駄話はするはずがないし
マーラに何でバプッパかとつけたんでしょうかと
花が持っているというね
そういうもうちょっと知識的なことを言う前に
一般的に説明して それで我々は自分の体をすごいありがたいものだと思っている
人間の世界はもう心っていうのはいまだに考えたことはないんですね
我々の文化の中でずっとやってきたものは肉体のためにでしょうし
肉体をどうやって維持管理するのか
肉体をどうやって可愛がってあげるのか
と それしか考えてないんです
科学発見 発展もすべて肉体に何とかしてあげるためなんです
火星でいろいろ何て言いますかね
この作ろうとか何とかとかね
宇宙で何とか宇宙センター作って
そこで人間住めるように何とか作ろうとか
いろいろ夢物語いっぱいあるでしょうに
それって何のため？単なる肉体のためなんですね
やがて地球はもう人が住めなくなったところで
あのー どこに 月でもどこでもいいところで開発して開拓して
人間に人間が住めるようにどうすればよろしいかとかね
空気がないんだから巨大なドーム作らなくちゃいけないんだとか
ではドームはどうやって作るのかとかね
それで空気の循環をどう作るのかとかね
で そこで自給自足にしなくちゃいけないんだから
どういう植物を栽培すればよろしい
そういうふうな まだ夢ばっかりですけど
SFだけの話でね いっぱいサイエンスフィクション的な話はもういっぱい作ったりする
一人も心のことは抱えて考えてないんです
で 新しい何か機械開発するんだよと言ったら
それは肉体のためなんです
時々脳もいじる機械やりますよ
それも面白いことは肉体のためなんですよ
この機械 頭につけておけば脳波が良くなりますよと
そうすると頭が良くなってまた仕事ができます
それでよく食っていられるんだよとゲスなっちゃうんです
それで人間持っているあらゆる努力
すべての能力 すべてのエネルギーを
この腐りかけている肉体のために使っているんです
衰えて必ず死んで土に戻る
そのために使っているんです
それっていうのはものすごく無駄な話なんですよ
論理的に見ると それである人に私はこの体は借り物だと
レンタルだと思ってくださいと言った覚えがあります
ありがたく理解してくれなかったんですけど
で 体がレンタルしたものだと思えばいかに楽かと
我々は何か品物をレンタルする
なぜレンタルするのかというと
これは高くて もう買うつもりはない
まず一生使うつもりは全くない
もう例えばカバンレンタルをする
外国旅行しようと思って
カバンというのは大きいし
いっぱい荷物入れなくちゃいけないんだから
そんなものは買ってもね
まあ一番高いものでも四万
五万あたりで買えますよ
五万以下 まあそれはどうったことないやといって
分割払いでも買っちゃえばいいんじゃないかなと
と思うかもしれませんが
買っちゃうとこれ一生自分の部屋に入れておかなくちゃいけないんだから
外国旅行はもう１週間だけなのに １
週間はものすごい便利で役に立つし
全然もう邪魔じゃないんです
帰ってきた時点からえらい迷惑で邪魔でしょうに
帰ってあの荷物あっちこっち置いたらこれからえらい邪魔者
だからある人はもうレンタルしようと
で 楽をするためでしょうに
それでカバンをレンタルしたとしたら
その人にはあまり困ることはない
ただ レンタル料金を払ってカバンを返しちゃえばいいんです
帰ったら だからといって
あまり残酷にいい加減に使っちゃうと
やっぱり弁償しなくちゃいけなくなるんですね
だから まあそれなりに丁寧に使って
あっちこちぶつけたり
まあもうその上に車を動かしたりとか
カバンの上に これどれぐらい硬いかもう調べてみましょうとか
カバンの上で飛び跳ねたりしたり
そういうくだらないことをしないで
カバンを持って行って
荷物を持って使って また持ってきて
はい どうぞと返せばいいでしょうに
それで気楽なんです そこでレンタルで取ったカバンに金具を入れ替えたり
ものすごい綺麗な高いお金でいろんなバッジを貼ったり
誰かすごい一流の絵描きさんに頼んで
もう何かちょっとデザインしてくれと頼んだり
例えばもうそれからもうもう金のチェーンをつけたりとか
また宝石も一つつけたりして
それ誰かに盗られたら困りますからといって
あの こういう細工やってる人のところで
これきちんとネジでつけてもらったりすると
すごいお金かかってるでしょうに
でも結局は帰ってから返さなくちゃいけないでしょうに
返せばどうなるのかというと
カバンはあらゆることでいじったんだからって弁償しなさいと
自分がもう例えば五百万円ぐらいもカバンにお金かかってますよ
なのに返す時はカバンの値段も弁償しなくちゃいけない
文句聞かない 私はこちらあの金のベルトつけてあげたんではないかと
ただ 私たちの商売にしてみれば
それは関係ないんだと
かえって邪魔だと これは誰も借りないかなっちゃうんだけど
あんたは商売に迷惑をかけたんだと
だからカバンの値段を弁償してくださいと
これ持っていってくださいと言ったら
その人はもういりません
そんなことをやる人は理性的だと思いますかね？思わないでしょうに
だから このレンタルした体に我々はどれほどお金と財産
お金とエネルギーをかけていますかというと
いくらかけても年取って死ぬんですよ
死ぬ時はひどい目に弁償までしなくちゃいけないんですよ
今までの生き方で ものすごいだらしない生き方をしたんだから
そこから地獄に落ちなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 人間の知識とすべて地球上にあるエネルギーと人間が持っている精神的なエネルギーとすべて
どうせ腐って捨ててしまう体のために使う
心育てるためには 1円も使いたくない
そういうことで 人間っていうのは無知なせいでやってはいけないことのみをしているんです
たまたまやってはいけないことをやっているというわけよ
こんな可愛い話じゃないんです
たまたま変なことをやりますよって
それは可愛いんですよ
そんなもんじゃないんです
やってはいけないことのみやっているんです
いくら健康食品食ってるんだからといって
病気にならないわけじゃないでしょうに
長生きするためにあれこれとやったとしても死なないでしょうに
だからやってはいけないということは明確にわかるんです
例えば もう健康健康ばかり考えて
もう厳密に食べ物を選んで選んで選んで選んで食べている人に限って
体が常に病気 そういう人に限って
なんのことなく癌やらあれやこれやとか現れてくる
その人に限って ほんのちょこっと病気になったってもなかなか治らない
医者にブーブーと文句言いながら
病院から病院もう旅を出る
旅に出る 薬は効かない
結局早死になる で なぜかと
これやってはいけないことをやっているんだから
この法則はわからない
この人々は 体のために
健康のために 長生きするためにとと思うたびに
心がどんな風に機能しているのかと
心がギュギュウギュギュと怯えているんですよ
穏やかな気持ちでいたことはないんです
ご飯食べてもものすごい苦しみで
ものすごい苦しみを感じながらご飯を食べているわけです
このご飯 本当に大丈夫だな
どこで作ったものでしょうか？とかね
本当に無農薬で作ったんでしょうか？とかね
それで思考能力ないんだから
大体ビニール袋に印刷するだけで十分ですよ
みんなに どんなもう脂肪しかない食べ物でも
ダイエットのためにと書いておけば売れるんです
だからその嘘を書いてはいけないんだから
体重を気になる方へ コレステロールを気になる方へとかね
水分線でもあるんですよ
だから裁判でも訴えられません
どうして書いてないんだから
そのもうコレステロールを気になる方へといった食べ物を食べて
私は心臓発作起こしたんだと
コレステロール高くてとかね
だから弁償しなさいと訴えられません
だってこれ食べればコレステロール減りますよと書いてないんだから
ただコレステロール気になる方へ
健康を考える現代人にとか
それでこの心っていうのは怯えてるんです
やばいぞと 病気になったらやばいぞ
癌になったらやばいぞということでもう癌なってもないのにそればっかり認識する
病気になってもないのにそればかり認識する
だからみんな知らないのは物質は心が作るんだということ
それは事実なんですけど
まだ科学者が言ってないんだからね
嘘ですね 私が言っても
あと誰かが発見すると
まああなた何言うんでしょうか
ああいう人も言ってますから
ということになるんです
だから この結局は体は心が作っているんです
だから癌になったらやばいぞと思うと
それは言語でしょう 感覚的には癌をイメージしているんです
癌をイメージしてそれに怯えるんです
だからとっくに心が癌を作っているんです
だからなるんです で だから私はこの簡単に病気治す方法というのは病気を忘れることなんで
切り離すことなんです
体に病気が出たら それを心から切り離しちゃう
関係ないんだ 私は忙しいんだと
切り離したらもうすごい肉体的な病気だったら
もう一応 1ヶ月間ぐらい
もう元に戻るまで 細胞新しく生まれ変わるまで時間かかりますけど
普段よりはかなり早く再生して元に戻るんです
でもこれができないでしょ？切り離せるっていうことはもう執着しかないんだからね
私の 私のという俺しかないんだから
この方法は使えないんです
一般の方々には 心で切り離しちゃえばもうたちまち治ることもあります
時々お釈迦様もそういうことをなさって
一応記録までありますけどね
お釈迦様が治療を受けたという記録は 1つもないんです
病気になった記録はあるんです
治療は一回だけで それも怪我の手当
その怪我もすごい短い時間でもう治りました
私はそれは本当なのかと自分でも
研究したことありますよ
自分の体で 前はもうしょっちゅう怪我するんです
後でその業終わったかはわからないんですけど
もう最近もこの前も怪我しましたけど
もう跡はなく まだ跡あります
もうあと 1週間で跡消えると思います
で 私にとってはそんなのはもう日常茶飯事のことだから
怪我するのは 私はした怪我が全部傷跡残ったならば体中傷だらけだと思いますよ
傷跡はないんです それでこのあまりにも激しく傷つけて筋肉が離れてかなりダメージ受けちゃう時だけ傷跡残るんですけど
でないと残らない それでただ怪我しただけだったら
私はだいたい 1分すぐ内で
もうもう血が出るのをやめてもらってつなげてもらうんです
つなげるんですよ 切れたものを
つなげてからはまだまだつなげたばっかりだから
このもう固めてないんだから
ちょっと一日ぐらいそこら辺はいじらないで気をつけておくんです
忘れておくんです 気をつけるよりは
次の日は何のことなくもうつなげた跡だけ残っているんです
しかし あのあれ あれ 何かバンドエイド何か貼っちゃうと終わり
結構時間かかる だからもうただみるみるうちにつなげますから
それは同じ方法でやるんですよ
必ず離せると 切り離すと
仕事があるんだったら
病気になっても同じ方法で切り離すんです
切り離したらすぐ瞬時にも治るんです
治るかどうかは私分かりませんだけど
自分はもうない 知らない
忙しいんだから こうやって元に戻ってみたら
あんまやっぱりないということになるんです
だからお釈迦様はしょっちゅうそういう方法で
もうやっぱりこの切り離す心からね
ということで 薬を使わないで
もうずっとあの厳しい生き方はね
していたんです もう大変な厳しい生き方でしたからね
あの生き方なんかもう想像もできない
今は 外で寝るとかやられちゃいますからね
だから このすごく その心が体を維持管理しているんです
その心が欲張りで 怒りで
憎しみで 恐怖で 不安で
もうあらゆる煩悩で汚れていると
ろくな体にはならないんですね
だからもう誰でも寿命終わったら死ぬんだから
それはどうったことはないんですよ
80歳で寿命だったら 80歳で死にますけど
その間でもずっと病院
病院 歩く病院で生きることっていうのはもうあまりにも不幸でしょうに
それなりに怪我やら事故に遭ったら
それぐらいの出来事があっても
それなりに健康でいてポツンと死ぬということは一応理想的でしょうに
自然に年取って 自然に衰えて死ぬと
それできるのは やっぱり心をそれなりに管理している人なんですね
怯え 恐怖感 欲 怒り 憎しみがない人なんですね
だから悟らない人にある唯一の手段は慈しみを育てることなんです
だから欲と怒り 憎しみの代わりにもう心はもう慈しみの念でいっぱいにしておけば
もうあの奇跡は効くんです
すぐ瞬時に病気治ります
なかなかそれも実践できないしね
あまりも我が強くて 素直に正直に慈しみは生まれてこない
で 苦労する 慈しみというのを始めてやりだしちゃうと
もう楽しくてたまらない瞑想なんですよ
それで何言いたいんでしょうかというと
この人間の知識 能力 すべての力をどうせ鎖かかっている体のために使っていると
それがおかしい 理性的じゃない
体はほんのちょっと借りたもので
だから必要ですよ 借りたんだから
レンタルしたんだから
それはそこそこ丁寧に使っちゃえばいいんです
そんなにエネルギーかける必要ないんです
弁償しなくちゃいけない羽目になることをしてはいけないんです
体など人殺しまでするんだから
銀行強盗までするんだから
例えば ある男がこの最近の六歳六ヶ月の赤ちゃん殺しちゃって
で ニュースで聞くと このもうミルク飲まなかったんだと
だから頭叩いたんだと
で 子供が死んじゃったんですよ
この連中何者かと で とにかく自分の体のことですよ
赤ちゃんのことは心配してないんです
赤ちゃんミルク飲むか飲まないか
そんなのは誰もわからないんだからね
自然にもう赤ちゃんのことはすごい可愛いと心配する親だったら
別にもう飲まなかったら飲まなかったで
飲みたかったら飲みたかったで
その向こうの要求に自分が合わせて面倒見るんであって
そのためには自分の自由を失うんですよ
子供が一時半で起きて
お腹が空いて泣き出しちゃうと
母親は寝たばっかりやと
やっと寝付いたんだということは聞かないでしょうに
で 疲れて疲れて なんとかグズグズ寝て寝付いてくるところで
赤ちゃんが起きて泣いちゃうと
もう普通の女だったらもう文句言いながら起きてまだおっぱいあげるんですよ
それで疲れて疲れてもう嫌々とは文句は言うんだけど
それでもって赤ちゃん殺そうとはしないしね
だから正しく育てる場合は
どうしても自分の自由なんかひとかけらもないんですよ
子育て 子育ての場合は
そこで肉体を大事に思っちゃうと子供殺しちゃうんです
自分にとってはもう早く飲めというぐらいですね
今ミルク飲む時間だからと
そんなのは赤ちゃんの世界ではないんだから
そういう考え方は １時間
赤ちゃん何時間ごとに飲むんですかね
知りませんだけど ３時間 ３
時間ごとに寝るんだから
じゃあ前飲んだのは今ちょうど３時間だから
はいと言ったっても これはこんな決まりないんですよ
もっと先にお腹が空いて泣く場合もあるし ３
時間も経ってるのにそんな気になってない時もあるし
時々ミルクのあげ方ダメだったら飲まないんです
心が通じてないとまずいんですよ
いくら丁寧に測って温度を測ってミルク作っても
気持ちが入ってないとまずい
飲めないんです 赤ちゃんの時はまだまだ生命は概念入ってないんだから
その心の気持ちはよくわかるんですね
だから母に簡単に飲ませられるでしょうに
もしかしたらあのケースの場合でも
もうただはい どうぞという感じで口にほにゅう液させただけやと思いますね
こんな何これという感じで
赤ちゃんがそれをもう飲まない
吸わなかったんですね
それで頭を叩いちゃうと
まだもう骨もできてないし
そのままグタッと子供は止まってしまって死んじゃったんですね
だから なんでやあのこと
ただくだらない自分の肉体に対する執着ですよね
だから銀行強盗もするは
戦争も起こすは 人は殺す
あらゆることを世の中でやってますね
全てとにかく肉体 肉体主義で
心っていうところには誰一人も考えていない
しかし 全て心が一番にしているのに
ですから その順番で心が解放してほしいんだから
集中力を育てて まず肉体って本当に何者かと理解してほしいんですね
そうすると 泡のようにブクブクブクブクと
もう現れて消えていくものだったら
放っておけばいいということになるんですよ
泡っていうのはどうせ弾けるんだからね
放っておけばいいでしょうに
別の檻を作ってあげたり
あれこれとかしたっても
弾ける時は弾けるんです
だからお釈迦様はこの物質的に我々の体も医学的には細胞ですけど
細胞のことはあまりインドで考えてなかったんで
エネルギーのことしか考えなかったんですけどね
エネルギーでできてあって
エネルギーっていうのは止まることなくずっと消えていくんですよ
エネルギーっていうのは止まらないんだから
流れるもんだから 流れなきゃエネルギーじゃないんだから
だから肉体 肉体 私の体
私の体といっても ずっと変わっているものなんですね
あるエネルギーは出ていくわ
その代わりにまたエネルギーは入ってくるわ
エネルギーは食べ物からだけじゃないんですよ
それもすごい現代人の勘違いで
何でも食い物からだと
体に必要だけど ほんの一部なんですね
食べ物から入るのは それは材料が出て行っちゃうと
物質的に体から 新しく作るために材料が必要になるんですね
それだけの食べ物で で
エネルギーといえばもう食べ物だけではなくなっちゃうんですね
いろいろエネルギーを入れて入れる
入れるというんじゃなくて
入るは入ったものはまた出ていくわ
それが自分の体っていうことで
こんなのはどうしても私の体っていうことはもう言えるものじゃありませんと
初めも私のものではないし
今も私のものではないんだと
これからこの肉体は私のもようになるわけでもないんだと
そこを考えたら 私の浮かんだ単語っていうのは
レンタルという現代言葉世界からはね
レンタルしたものは初め私のものじゃないし
使っている途中でも私のものじゃないし
返してから私のものじゃないんです
ただ レンタルしている間は自分が使っているだけ
その時間では自分にはちょっといい加減にそれを使っていけないというね
まあ約束もある それだけのことで
そういうことで体に対する執着を捨てると
言うと残るのは心は大事ではないかという話
今まで喋ったのはそういうことだからね
肉体支配管理しているのは心ではないかと
そこで我々はどんな もし私の今までの説明を理解したならば
次に来るのはやっぱりわかった
心を大事にしなくちゃいけないんだ
心こそ私だという 考え方に入っちゃうんですね
もし私の今までの話を理解したならば
それで次に聞くんです
どうすれば心を大事にするのかとか
どうすれば心をしっかりと育てられるのかとか
どうすれば心はものすごい強化することができるのかということで
肉体にあった執着 そのまま心に引っ越しさせるんです
これももうほど遠い稀なことで
いくら私が喋っても肉体こそ全てだという概念からは逸れませんと思いますけど
もし万が一誰かが ああそうか
分かった もう肉体はどうでもいい
と思った時点で やっぱり心を大事にしなくちゃというところに行くんです
そこで自分の心はどうやって清らかにして成長して
自由自在に何でも自分希望通りにさせるのかと
だってすごいすごい甘い
甘いじゃなくて もう美味しい話でしょう
病気でも瞬時に治せますよと言ったこと
それは嘘じゃないんです
私もやって結構やりますから
だって薬飲んでないんだから
もうあと何ヶ月間かもう60になりますよ
まあ風邪なんか引いたら薬飲みそうと思って時たまたま風邪薬置いておくんですけど
部屋に薬がある限りは風邪は引かないんですね
これ誰か誰かに配って何もない時にない時になったらもう風邪引いちゃって
もう薬もないという すごい業がいいんです
で 今度もまあ４回 ５回ぐらい風邪ものすごく引きそうになって
もう細菌も入って結構混乱しちゃったんですけど
風邪引かずに治す 止めてもらったら止めろと
もう風邪引いてのんびりする暇がないということで
で だからこれできればすごいありがたい話でしょうに
で そういうことでどうなるのかというと
肉体に対する執着がそのまま
あの煩悩が心に移っちゃうんです
そうすると心を大事にしなくちゃいけない
いけないということに
人間 執着はそちらに移行する
そこでお釈迦様の番目の説教が入るんです
心に執着するなよと 結局今までもあなた苦しませたのは肉体じゃなくて心だよと
肉体はもう借り物で もう別にどうったことはない
なんで苦しんだのかというと
それまた心なんですね
そこで次のステージで
心に対する執着も 体を捨てたと同じく捨てなくちゃいけない
そこはこちらの偈で チェッワナマーラッサパプッパカーニ
マーラを切ってくださいと
マーラっていうのは もう悪魔でもよろしいし
死をでもよろしいし この死ということで
仏教は何を意味するのかというと
この輪廻転生を意味するんですね
エネルギーっていうのはずっと続けちゃいますから
物質エネルギーももうそれ続ける物質
体は私のものじゃないんだからね
物質世界に返さなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう返すなくちゃけどずっと返してるんだからね
物質からエネルギーを物質エネルギーいただいて返しちゃぐるいただいて流してるんだから
そこはまたやがて心が離れると
そのままボーンと肉体を返さなくちゃいけないんです
扱い方悪かったら心が次にその弁償を払うために不幸なところに生まれ変わっちゃうんです
適当にレンタルやと思ってただ使って返すだけだったら
弁償を払うことにはならないんです
で 心がやっぱり死んでも
まだ次にまた体を構築する
そうするとまた同じプロセスを繰り返さなくちゃいけないんです
そこで体捨てても また別な体に入っちゃう
入るんじゃなくて別な体作るんです
で 体を この体はDNA作ったものじゃないんですよ
別世界から心が入ると
その心が形を持ってるんです
その形に合わせて体が出来上がるんです
親からもらった細胞で
だから兄弟は同じじゃないでしょう
なんだかんだ言っても違うんです
だから私の体形っていうのは
この 結構変わりますよ
もうなんとなくこのもう骨組みとあれと似ているだけで
心が変わるたびにかなり変わります
時々全くわからないぐらい変えることもできます
性格が変わると変わるってことはよく知ってるでしょうに
体は全然変わらないんだったらね
どうやって我々は人を見ていろんなことを言うんでしょうかね
あんた随分悩んでるみたい
いろんな苦労したみたいですよとかね
何のことなく平気でみんな言ってるでしょうに
誰も心を感じてない目で肉体だけ見て言ってるでしょうに
体が変わります だからやっぱり体の形まで心は作るんですよ
だから生まれ 新しい生まれになってくると
そちらで心が自分でそれなりの形を作っちゃって
その形に適した場所に行っちゃうんです
だから生まれ死んだ人は必ずしも人間になるということはほとんどない
人間らしい心を持ってないんだからね
人間というのはかなりレベル高い
かなりの立派な精神なんですよ
なってないでしょう すごいだらしない
ほぼ動物に近い すごくイライラすることっていうのは
この知識能力っていうのは動物よりもダメな時っていうのは
それやっぱりその時は我慢できなくなる
何だとこれと 動物に負けてどうするのかなと
ちっこ見えてます 人格的に負けてるんだのに
だからとにかく死ぬ時の心のレベルに合わせて心はもうそういう形
自動的になっちゃうし
それに適したどこかに行っちゃうんです
動物のレベルになっちゃうと
どこか動物の ところに入り込んじゃって
その形に次からなるんですよ
犬のお腹に入っちゃったら猫は生まれませんよ
犬になるんですよ 犬になっても
その犬が持ってる心によって犬が変わるんです
だからかわいくてどうしても飼ってやりたい犬にもなるし
もう飼いたくない もう捨てたいという犬にもなっちゃうし
時々引っ越しはしたいんですけど
引っ越しするところで犬は飼えないんだから
もう苦労して犬のために大変苦労して
どこかにお金も高いお金も家賃も払っているケースもあります
しょうがない もっと楽なところに引っ越しする
そうするとそちらで犬は飼えません
じゃあポイ捨てると 捨てられる場合もありますね
だからその時でも やっぱり心の心がものを言うんですよ
犬の方がしっかりしているんだったら
人間にはもう捨てられないんですね
でも引っ越しはしたいんです
それで引っ越しやめるんです
それでマーラっていうのはそういう輪廻転生のことで
このエネルギーはポツンとストップしないんだから
エネルギーっていうのは流れるという意味ですから
瞬間たりとも止まることはない
エネルギーは だから肉体捨てても肉体支配管理したものと心っていうのは肉体よりも巨大なエネルギーだから
すぐ流れちゃう そこもやめろと言うんです
そのエネルギーも完全に消しちゃえと
エネルギーを消すということは
もうなかなか物理世界の物理学世界ではちょっと理解できないことだから
ブッダはもっと違う論理なんですね
無常論理だから だからこのエネルギーの不滅法則じゃないんです
仏教は 別な法則なんです
だからやたらにそういう単語を輪廻転生するために使えない
本当は エネルギーは消えないでしょうとか言ったら
みんなもう馬鹿だからああそうでしょうとかね
わかってないのに そんな感じで輪廻転生する
そうすると まあそうかなとか
そこで止まるだけで それも完全な説明じゃないんです
組み合わせ論なんですね
だから瞬間瞬間物事を組み合わせてエネルギーが現れて
それとまた次に物事と組み合わせて次のエネルギーが現れるという強烈なスピードで組み合わせて新しいエネルギーが現れてくるんだと
それで理解できない人には炎たとえているんです
じゃあ炎を見てください
それでわかります 炎っていうのはあらゆる
組み合わせて炎があるんであった
だから組み合わせるものがある限りは炎は消えませんだけど
永久的というわけじゃなくて
瞬間瞬間変わってるんです
だから無常でありながら続くという
炎っていうのは瞬間瞬間消えるんです
消えて次の炎なんです
だから炎を維持するためにずっと燃料が行かなくちゃいけないんです
そこで燃料切れと 燃料供給切れたら炎が消えるんです
どこ行ったか聞くなよと
炎の例えしかないんですよ
仏教の仏典では そこでどうやって心の
心はエネルギーであったら
あるならば たとえ涅槃に入っても
そちらでどんな形で心あるのかと聞きたくなりますが
それはもう法則がわからない人の質問で
それ以上は語れませんよと
語ることを思考する子はここまでやと
ということでもうおっしゃってますから
概念があれば 言葉があれば
思考することあれば 全てここまでやと
という この悟り 悟るちょっとの前のところまでなんです
悟りというところからは終わりと
悟りという単語さえも俗世間の単語なんです
だから消えるという言葉になっているのです
他単語も存在しない 涅槃という単語以外は
それで何言いたいかというと
だから心はなんで続くのかと
エネルギーだから続くのは当たり前だと言っても
これが炎のようなものなんですよ
いつでも燃料を与えているんだから
もう燃料も外からなければ自分で開発するという働きなんですね
だから心の中にある燃料で次の心が燃えて
そのエネルギーで次の心が燃えるということで
それで燃料を与えないということにするんです
煩悩というのはそういうことで
で それでこの体に対執着捨てた人は次に心の執着を捨てる
心の執着を捨てなさいということは
チェットアナマーラッサ パプッカカーニ
この花持っているマーラを切れということで
燃料切れということなんです
私のブッダゴーサ長老もテーラワーダの世界でもわかってない
この偈にしても明確にお釈迦様がこの文学的に語っているんですけど
何語りたかったのかというのをちょっと調べてないみたいですね
だから でもやっぱり悪魔にというか
このキューピッドには
あの矢がありますし 弓はあまり考えてないんで
矢には花が 5つ付いてるんですね
これはもう神話で別に現実ではありません
ただのインド人の神話で
でもわざわざそれを使ったのは
おそらくお釈迦様がこの弓に
矢にある花の 5つを考えたかもしれません
だから心にある煩悩が 5つに分けて説明しないと
で 今私に思い出せるのはこの五蓋ぐらいですけどね
まあ他の三要件というと
数が 10個あるし 結と言えば願と言えば 4つでしょうし
五蘊ではないですか  五蘊じゃない
うーん 渇愛と言えば 1つでしょうし
渇愛と無明では 2つだけになるし
やっぱり 5つにしなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると残るのは五蓋なんです
五蓋の中にも全ての煩悩入ってるんです
パンチャニーバラナ ニーバラナっていうのは涅槃に邪魔に
邪魔する意味なんですね
涅槃に邪魔するものは 5つやというんだから明確なんですね
お釈迦様の単語から言えば
ニーバラナ 涅槃に邪魔するんだからニーバラナというんですけど
辞書の意味はもう障害だけなんですけど
だからこの何でしたっけ？五蓋は
カーマッチャンダ ビアパーダ
ティーヌミッダ ウッダッチェクッチェ
ヴィチキッチャというところですね
カーマッチャンダっていうのは欲
愛で ビアパーダは怒り
瞋恚で ウッダッチェクッチェは情報と
後悔 ティーナ・ミッレ・バーマは昏沈睡眠でしょうし
ウシヴィッチャっていうのは疑いなんですね
疑っていうのはもめ事ということで
その五取は このー ちょっと減っただけでも禅定に入ります
まあ沈んだだけでも それは完全に切っちゃうと
もう悟りなんです そういう説明にしなくちゃいけないやと思いますけどね
それからアダッサナ マッチュラージャッサ ガッチェと
もうマッチュラージャ
この世の中の人々に 輪廻には捕まらないところに行けと
涅槃を体験しなさいと
それがその偈の本当の意味なんです
俗世間的な意味は残念ながらないんです
これの日本訳どうなってますかね
四十六 はぁ 難しいんですかね
この偈は  体に対する執着を捨てる
それから心に対する執着も捨てると
それで涅槃ということなんです
一切の執着を捨てることは涅槃なんです
何にもありがたいことはないということなんです
うん 一般人 一般世間に何か役に立つ意味っていうのを考えたんだけど
なかなかないんですよ
まぁ言えるところは そんなに体に執着するなよというぐらいでね
体はレンタルやレンタルしたものであるということで
気楽に生活すればいいんじゃないかなと
そんなにゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャもう全ての精神力と財産を肉体のために使うんじゃなくてね
ほどほどに ほどほどにお仕事をして
ほどほどに食べて ほどほどなところで生活してすればいいんじゃないかと
時間の余裕もあって 精神的な力の余裕もあって
今余裕どころじゃない
仕事しただけでももうクタクタ疲れるでしょうに
道が間違ってるんだからなんですよ
みんな仕事をすること精一杯だから
それでも収入足らないしね
あまりにも間違ってますよ
二 三時間仕事をすれば
一週間ぐらい食えるならば
すごく楽で便利でしょうに
なんでその道を失ったんですかね
それで理性やと言うんですかね
科学やと文明やと あれやこれやとか
だって科学という文明も何もなかった昔はね
みんなもうちょっと一ヶ月間ぐらいこちょこちょっとなんかやって
それで一年食べてるんだから
いたんだから だって田んぼを削ったってもね
田んぼを削って種まいて
じっと待っていればいいんだからね
初産から 守るだけだから
それはさして難しいことじゃないしね
また守るのも楽しいでしょうしね
田んぼで動物が入らないように鳥が来ないようにとかね
追い出したり走り回ったりして
そこで水をちょっとあげたりやらせたりして
それから稲刈りしたら
これで一年食べられますからね
余裕はいっぱいあったんです
それで農業は科学的になっちゃったんです
これで世界は飢えているんです
1 分間で子供は飢えて死ぬ人っていうのは 1.5 か 1.6 ですね
もっとですね ２人くらい死にます
食べるものがなくて この科学世界で １
分間で軍事力はどれぐらいでしたっけ
113万円以上使ってます
世界で軍事力 １分間で
人殺すために 東大の先生なんて一人が何でも１分で１秒に計算するんです
一見バカバカらしく見えるんですけど
やっぱりさすがそれなりに哲学もあります １
分間にしてみれば １分間で世界で炭酸飲料はどれぐらい飲んでるんでしょうかとか
彼が言うのは 10%下げればね
軍事費はね 世界はむっちゃ豊かになるんだと
全部消せと言ってない
10%ぐらい 人間というのは利己的やと言うんでしょうかね
戦々 people 殺しに使う
それって人殺しを楽しむんだからじゃなくて
自分の肉体を守るためなんですね
そんなにもやるんですかね
それで何か得ているんですかね
何も得てないでしょうね
人殺すことで だからそういう人の話に乗って
もう何か似ている ブッダも似ていることを言っているんだよというと
ものすごく私はもう気分悪くなるのはもうどうしようもないんです
私は親戚でも捨てますよ
もうこういうもう屁理屈をもうブッダに対してそこ何か言っちゃうと
悪いことをしたっても全然それはへっちゃら
それはもうただ悪いことしてるだけ
いい加減なやつやと 言って心配してなんとか助けますけど
結構いますよ 自分の国でも説法に行かない
私は まさかどこかでちょっとブッダに対して失礼な態度を取ったという
微妙に態度取ったら はい
行かないよ それ言わない
その代わりに無意識的に切って捨てるんです
捨てられてる すごい不幸になるんですけど
本人が気づいてちゃんと謝ってやり直す限りはどうにもくどることもできない
自分の頃だったら真っ最中でやめますよ
説法 知ってる人々はすごく怖くなりますからね
ブッダの教えって真面目な人々はね
言ってさっさともう全部変えてみんなに怒鳴りつけて謝らせますからね
だいたい問題になりませんだけど
でもそのショックはすごい巨大です
だから世の中の話には乗るんじゃないんです
結局はね 安全で平和で豊かでしっかり生きたければ
ブッダの言葉を聞くしかほか道がない
もういくら調べても そういうことで
我々はそんなにね 体に必死にならないで
ほどほどそこそこで生きていればいいんじゃないかなと
いうことで考えてください
そんなに死に物狂いで仕事をしたりとかではなくて
能力を発揮して 短い時間で結構金儲かる方を考えればいいんです
お金がなければ生きていられませんだからね
仕事するのは面白くてたまらんと思って一日中仕事したって
ろくな収入がなかったら全然意味がないんですよ
それよりは収入がたくさんある仕事を選びましょうと
もうバイトに行くにしても
時給が高い方が選んだ方がいいんじゃないんですかね
時給はもう 300円やというところでね
もう 1 日仕事しなきゃ収入にならんだから
だったら時給 800円のところに行く
800円は夜しかないんだったら
夜何時間仕事すればいいでしょうに
お金があるんだから昼は自分の時間でしょうに
それですごく頭を使って仕事っていうのは本当はすごい単純ですよ
頭を使うんだったらすごい単純にこなせることはわかるんです
これ怯えちゃうんだから
興奮するんだから 緊張するんだからもう失敗ばっかりで
だから時給は 800円でしたっても
精神的に燃えて苦労するところはもう値段つけないんですよ
もう自己破壊になってるんだから
だから収入も結局は割に合わないんですね
だから仏教の世界なら無駄は全部やめる
無駄なことっていうのはもう全部もうやめちゃって
必要なことしかしないということになるんです
そういう世界だったらつまらない世界になるのかと
そうでもないんですよ
例えば仏教はいくらか都会的な教えですけどね
都会的な教えでもあって
農民の教えなんです すごい面白いです
だからこの街をすごく美しく綺麗に整理整頓するとかね
それは仏教的なんですよ
道路はなんか綺麗に整理整頓して明かりをつけてとかね
お釈迦様がいるところは 24時間ずっと明かりですからね
昔は 夜は明かり消しません
遠い昔でも それ無駄とは思わないんです
人間には明かりが必要ですからね
必要なことなんです でお釈迦様のところはほとんど人々はもう修行したり頑張ったりするんだから
もし夜でもいつでも誰かがアドバイスしなくちゃいけないことになると
お釈迦様のところに行かなくちゃいけないし
お釈迦様のところはいつでも 24時間明かりはつけている
阿羅漢たちは遠慮しないで明かり消しちゃうと
もうドア叩けないでしょうに
ブッダのところに だから私は考えても
例えば人間に必要な風に美しい街を作るとか
建物なんかは人間に便利
作るとか それは削除はしませんよ
無駄をやめる  四十億円の飛行機買うとか軍事飛行機買うとかね
そういうことはしない
その四十億円の買うと別なものを買うとかね
みんなに使えるもの 例えば日本に日本のものすごいもうちょい豊かだったらね
韓国から北朝鮮からってそういう危険はないと思いますけどね
豊かじゃないんだからね
無駄ばっかしやってるんだから
それが腹が立つんですよ
こちらはもう食べ物安くてすごい品質のいい服やら何だかんだいくらでもあったりして
こんなちょこっとのお金で買えるならば
もう北朝鮮人でもなんとか来てね
こちら品物を買ってああ良かった
良かったと行くんだで
この国を崩壊させようと思わないんです
だから すごい豊かにいるということは
それなりに悪いことじゃないんです
昔だったら危ないこともありましたけどね
まあそれでやられるというね
豊かで怠けることになっちゃうと
だから仏教は無駄なくせというところで
本当に無駄なくせと言であって
人間に便利なところまでなくせということを考えているわけじゃないんです
だから 例えば高い買い物をしようとした時でも
いきなり飛んで買うんじゃなくて
これが私にどうしても必要なのかということをね
ずっと豊かになってくるとどうしても必要ということはもうなくなりますけど
その場合はどうしても必要ということはないんだけど
楽しいんだから買いますよということになるでしょうね
では その払うお金に適した楽しみが得られるのかと考えた方がいいんですね
私は大画面で映画とかテレビとか見たいと思ってプロジェクターを買ったんですね
同時に講演に使うという気持ちもありましたけど
講演は毎日あるわけじゃないんだから
それで部屋でド派手に見せそうと計算したんです
買ってみたら結局自分に見る暇がないんですね
そうなるとそれは無駄遣いなんですね
もし暇があって もう映画とかもう大画面で見られるんだったら
スクリーンでね 無駄じゃないんです
で見過ぎがあって ランプも切れちゃって
新しいランプも入れなくちゃいけなくなったというならば
結構使ったということになります
それでどうしたんですか？と
やっぱり自分に見る暇がないんだから
こちらに置いておいたんです
一回 二回しか私の部屋に持っていったことはないんです
だから贅沢になってくると
例えばもう食べるものがとお腹が空いていると人は死ぬんだからね
食べるものはどうしても買わなくちゃいけない
そういう状態に日本はあるわけじゃないでしょうし
だから買い物はというと
やっぱり贅沢ものになっちゃうでしょうね
服を一つ買いたにしても
もう着るものがなくなっちゃって買ってるわけじゃなくて
もうちょっとおしゃれしたく買うでしょうに
それは贅沢ですね だから贅沢の場合は
どうしてもこれ私は必要でしたという思想がちょっと機能しなくなっちゃうんですね
その場合は これで私は期待している楽しみ
得られるのかと考えた方がいいんですね
ネックレスは買うかないかと
それには五百万円払うかないかというね
まあ買えようとすれば買えるし
しかしこのネックレスは私は何回つけるのかと
ずっと計算したっても
まあ二十年だったら五回ぐらいやってなってくると
自分期待する楽しみが得られないかもね
ただ守ることに大変になっちゃうんですね
やっぱりやめた方がいいやと
こういうことになるんです
そこですごいもうデザインもシンプルな
ほんのちょっとのチェーンとちょっとしたのペンダントがあって
これは十万円やと これどうでしょうか
これならしょっちゅう使えるんだと
普通に毎日のように首に付けてあったっても大丈夫だというと
これほとんど毎日のように首に付けたままでいられる
だったら何の重症もなくパッサパサと買った方がいいんです
そういうことで無駄をなくすんですよ
贅沢してはいけないということではないんです
贅沢できる人は贅沢はするんですけど
贅沢っていうのは楽しむ
余計に楽しむことだから
余計に楽しまなきゃ意味がないんですよ
例えば銀行にある 何でしたっけ
あれは あるでしょう あの
何て言いますか  貸出ですね
貸金  貸金ね そちらに放り込むために何で品物を買うんですかね
だからもうほとんど毎日のようにかけて指につけて首につけてる 10万円のネックレスだったら
全然空き巣には入りませんし
持っていかれませんし
だって首につけてるんだもん
道路で誰かにパクられたら
まあそれはそれで別に抱かれてすごい損というわけではないし
盗まれたってもの十分使ってるんだからね
それでも 500万円のネックレス買える人だから
10万円で買ってるんだから
全然痛くも痒くもないしね
500万円のネックレスの代わりに買ったものだから
なくなったって痛くも痒くもない
そういう風な生き方なんですね
仏教的に考える 贅沢してはいけないってことじゃないんです
フィリピンの昔の大統領の夫人
何でしたっけ？マルコス夫人
エメラルダ エメルダさんみたいに 40万足かな
足ぐらいね 靴をどこに何のために履くんですかね
人生は刑務所で終わる同等だからね
あれは正しい生き方じゃないし
自分のお金で買ったわけでもないし
全部国の財産を盗んだものだから盗人なんですね
盗んだお金で裁判かけていろいろもう解放されてもらったんですけどね
ぐちゃぐちゃ言って で
なんか選挙にも出るつもりなんですけど
もう立場がないんですけど
今現役でいるみたいですが
結局はもう驚く大盗人なんですよ
それは業がなくなるわけじゃないんですね
だから贅沢するのは悪くないんだけど
それも罪を犯さない程度で
自己破壊しない程度で
本当に楽しいんだったらやってもよろしいし
一度もドライブに行かない人は高価な車買う必要はないし
しょっちゅうドライブであっちこっち行くんだったら
かなり派手な車買っても別にどうってことないんですよ
それはやめなさいという無駄遣いということじゃないんです
しょっちゅうどこへ行っても車で行くんだったら
自分が車人生がすごく楽しいならね
だったら高価な高価な車買ってもよろしいし
たまにね かけるのに 3台もあるというと
それが無駄でしょうし
だからそういう生き方
世界的にやってますから
我々は人を殺してますよ
知らない 知らないうちに
だっていろんなところでもう食べ物はないわ
乾季になるわ もう洪水になるわ
地震が起こるわ もうあらゆる災害起こるでしょうに
そういう人々を助けてあげることはできないし
もう病気でもアフリカなんかものすごい人が死んでいくわ
エイズというのはものすごい広げていくでしょうに
もう次から次 次から次へと
もうお金がないんですね
だから一部がこうやってやって無駄にやっていることによって
もうものすごい人々が死んでいるんだから
これはもう殺していることと似ているんですよ
だから仏教的に報いしないね
しかし 自分がすごく楽しく贅沢できてると結構余裕があるんですよ
それで人が困った時はもう何のことなく助けてあげて
そうすると そういう人々も自分たちを守ってくれるんですよ
この人のおかげだと 憎しみません
だからブッダが俗世間に言うのは
そういう生き方はいいんじゃないかなと
そういうことを考えたところで
悪魔がこのある 6万目の天国にいる神なんですけど
さっさとお釈迦様のところに来て
だからそういう政治はブッダならできるでしょうと
だからこの人々のために
もう一度政治に戻ってくださいと
あなたには世界を政治することはできますよと
みんな従いますよ そうしたらお釈迦様に追い出されたんです
お前何考えてるんですか？と
ブッダは俗世間に戻ると思ってるんでしょうかと
ある日 お釈迦様考えたんですよ
こんな不公平な政治ではなくて
公平なみんなに公平な豊かな政治できないのかと
それはもうやればできるんだと思ったところで
あのマーラさんが来て
余計なことを言って追い出されたんですけど
だから一応観念的かもしれませんだけど
そういう政治システムは世の中仏教では考えてはいるんです
実行したケースはないんですけど
人間ですから やっているのは
だから決して仏教を人間に苦労しなさいよとかね
人生は空だよと言っても
だから苦しめなさいという意味じゃないんです
その程度でだけでも理解していただければありがたいと思います
このそんなにも体にしがみついて引っかかる必要はないんだということで
そこできたら やっぱり心にしがみついちゃいますから
次に集中力を育てて 心の煩悩をなくさなくちゃいけない
それはお釈迦様おっしゃっている最終的な解決方法なんです
そういうわけで話を終了いたします
どうもです